I wouldn't call them cult members would
you
uh no you know the definition of a cult
is a group of people who are excessively
supporting one another and a cause all
about Conformity and compliance and
intolerance of anyone who doesn't agree
with what their mission is okay that's
the definition of what the left is
engaged in right now speaking of Cults
all about Conformity and compliance and
heaven forbid you don't agree with them
isn't that the best by just about any
accurate definition
hardcore Maga is indeed a cult they have
beliefs and practices that are strange
or even Sinister including denying the
reality of the world insofar as climate
change covid the 2020 election results
they worship Trump as this Messianic
figure